وقع رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما
رئاسيا بشان التجنيد في الجيش تضمن
استدعاء 130 الف شخص للخدمه العسكريه
را
قوات فاغنر تعود الى حلبه الحرب
الاوكرانيه من جديد والمخابرات الامريكيه
تخاطب زيلنسكي عليك ان تستقيل وتلوذ
بالفرار اداره بايدن تخلط اوراق الحرب
الاوكرانيه بلغاريا تعلن قطع شريان الطاقه
الروسي الى الابد وبعد ان طردها من النيجر
باريس تنتقم من بوتين وقاده النيتو
يتحضرون على اراضي كيف اتفاق امريكي
بريطان اوكراني لهجوم جديد للاستيلاء على
زبروجيا بينما تحاول كزاخستان انجاز ما
عجزت عنه دول العالم في اوكرانيا وبوتين
يتقرب من الشعب الاوكراني بهذا القرار
السعوديه تشد عزمها للاتفاق مع اسرائيل
بضمانه من ابناء العمس عدو الانقلاب
تتجاوز حدود النيجر الى جيرانها الصبر
الغربي
ينفذ نفذت الحلول جفت التدخلات فشلت
الاسلحه لا شيء غربيا نجح في الحرب
الاوكرانيه ليقدم ضابط المخابرات الامريكي
السابق سكوت يتر نصيحه للرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي عثه فيها على ان يقدم
استقالته طوعيا ويلوذ بالفرار من البلاد
محذرا من ان زل نسكي قد يواجه غضب الضباط
الذين يشعرون بالخيانه بسبب عدم كفاءته
الراي الامريكي لم ينتهي عند هذا الحد حيث
كشفت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان استبدال رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه مارك مالي
بتشارلز براون اتي عند نقطه تحول في
اوكرانيا حيث بدا الغرب يشعر بالملل من
النزاع الذي طال امده وقد ياتي ذلك في
اسوا وقت ممكن حيث يظهر الغرب علامات على
نفاد الاسلحه والصبر تجاه اوكرانيا نفذ صب
الامريكيين من اوكرانيا فغيرت واشنطن
اوراقها الخاصه الامر زيدون حيره الا
يفترض ان يتم تغيير قاده اوكرانيا
التحركات تجاوزت الولايات المتحده لتشتت
في حلف النيتو باكمله ليتواجد على الارض
الاوكرانيه كل من الامين العام لحزب
الشمال الاطلسي ستولتنبرج ووزيري الخارجيه
الفرنسي والبريطاني في زيارات غير معلنه
جددوا فيها دعمهم لكييف وتوفير كل
احتياجاتها في الحرب ضد روسيا هذا ما ظهر
لكن ما خف لا يز زال تحت الطاوله بانتظار
ان يطفو على السطح يا ساده وهنا وزير
الدفاع الفرنسي سيباستيان ليغن يرافقه
ممثلون عن 20 شركه فرنسيه لصناعه الاسلحه
يصلون الى كيف كما افادت صحيفه لوفيغارو
وهنا اعلن ليغن ان باريس تعتزم الانتقال
من توريد الاسلحه لكييف الى ابرام العقود
العسكريه معها وفق وكاله فرانس بريس فيما
وعد وزير الدفاع البريطاني جران شامس
اثناء زيارته ل العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
بمزيد من الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا وكانت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قد ذكرت في وقت
سابق ان لندن تعتزم تزويد كياب بمعدات
عسكريه وذخيره اضافيه في الاشهر المقبله
فيما صرح وزير الدفاع عن بريطانيا ستنقل
اضافه الى ذلك عشرات الالاف من قذائف
المدفعيه الى اوكرانيا اما في بلغاريا
فصادق البرلمان على قرار التخلي عن النفط
الروسي بحلول الاول من اكتوبر
2024 حسب ما افادت وسائل الاعلام
البلغاريه على ارض المعارك الاوكرانيه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش
الروسي تمكن من احباط جميع هجمات قوات كيف
وعزز مواقعه على الخطوط الاماميه وقالت
الوزاره ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت
مقاتله من نوع سو 25 و26 طائره مسيره
واعترضت اربعه صواريخ اطلقتها قوات كيف من
منظومه هاي مارس الامريكيه مع
465 قتيلا من جنود الجيش الاوكراني خلال
يوم اليكم المصدر الذي نتصفح امامكم في
الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه هذا واعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه عن توجيه ضربات مكثفه
باسلحه عاليه الدقه بعيده المدى لمواقع
عسكريه اوكرانيه ونقاط تمركز للجيش
الاوكراني واضافت الوزاره ان الضربات
اسفرت عن تدمير مستودعات للذخيره ومراكز
تدريب وتجمعات للقوات الاوكرانيه وترسانات
كبيرتين من الاسلحه والذخائر كما تم
استهداف امدادات اسلحه اجنبيه صنع ومراكز
لوجستيه للقوات الاوكرانيه على محوري
دونيتسك و زبروجيا ياتي هذا بينما القت
مسيره اوكرانيه متفجرات على محطه توزيع
كهرباء في بلده روسيه قريبه من الحدود
الاوكرانيه ما ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء عن
خمس مناطق سكنيه ومستشفى في مقاطعه كورسك
حسب ما قال حاكم المقاطعه وها هو المصدر
يتحدث الدفاع الروسيه انها اسقطت 11 مسيره
اوكرانيه فوق منطقتين روسيتين واضافت
الوزاره ان ع مسيرات اسقطت في منطقه كورسك
وواحده في كالوجا جنوب غربي موسكو وفي شان
ذي صله قالت السلطات الروسيه ان مسيره
اوكرانيه القت متفجرات على محطه لتوزيع
الكهرباء في بلده بلايا الروسيه وان
الهجوم ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء في خمس
بلدات في المنطقه لتعود وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه وتعلن عن تسلم القوات الجويه
الفضائيه الروسيه دفعه جديده من مقاتلات
الجيل الخامس سو 57 وقاذفات سو 35 اس
متعدده المهام من الجيل الرابع الرد
الاوكراني جاء بعدما كشف مصدر مقرب من
السلطات ان الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلنسكي اتفق مع مسؤولين من الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا على خطه لشن هجوم جديد
في اوائل اكتوبر واضاف المصدر انه لتحقيق
هذه الاغراض تتمركز مجموعه كبيره من مشاه
البحريه التابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه في
منطقه نيكولاييف لعبور نهر دنيبرو وفي
الوقت نفسه تتمركز قوات خاصه تابعه لقوات
العمليات الخاصه الاوكرانيه والتي تم
تدريبها من قبل المدربين البريطانيين
ويخططون لاتخاذ اجراءات للاستيلاء على
محطه زبرج للطاقه النوويه هل تجدي هذه
الخطط نفعا امام الدب الروسي ليستمر الكر
والفر بين كيف وموسكو حيث قالت وكاله تاس
ان الرئيس الروسي وقع مرسوما بشان التجنيد
الاجباري واستدعاء 130 الف شخص للخدمه
بدايه من الخريف من جانبها قالت
الاستخبارات العسكريه البريطانيه ان من
المحتمل ان مئات من افراد ميليشيا واجنر
بداوا اعاده الانتشار في اوكرانيا واضافت
ان العمليه انجزت على مستوى الافراد
والمجموعات الصغيره التي تقاتل ضمن
الوحدات المواليه لروسيا في اوكرانيا هذا
واعلن الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي التقى
مساعد الزعيم الراحل لمجموعه فجنر
العسكريه يفجيني بريغوجين اندري تروشي
وطلب منه تدريب متطوعين للقتال في
اوكرانيا واضاف الكرملين ان تروشي يعمل
الان لدى وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بصفه رسميه
بعد ان كان كان مساعدا لزعيم فاغنر الراحل
ليتدخل الرئيس الكازاخستاني قاسم جمر
توكاييف بالوسطه هذه المره حيث اكد توكيف
ان روسيا واوكرانيا اعربت عن رغبتهما في
الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات الا ان شكل
المفاوضات بشروط تناسب الطرفين لم يتحدد
بعد وعلى عكس مجريات الحرب والمعارك وقع
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما يسمح
للمواطنين الاوكرانيين بدخول روسيا
ومغادرتها بموجب بطاقات الهويه الشخصيه
بما فيها منتهيه الصلاحيه الاحداث
والتطورات نقلت رايترز عن ثلاثه مصادر
اقليميه مطلعه على المحادثات ان السعوديه
عازمه على التوصل الى اتفاق عسكري يلزم
الولايات المتحده بالدفاع عنها مقابل
تطبيع العلاقات مع اسرائيل وانها لن تعطل
الاتفاق حتى لو لم تقدم اسرائيل تنازلات
كبيره للفلسطينيين من اجل اقامه دوله
مستقله لهم الى افريقيا قال المجلس
العسكري في بوركينا فاسو ان قوات الامن
واجهزه المخابرات احبطت محاوله انقلاب قبل
ايام قليله وذلك دون التطرق للتفاصيل اضف
المجلس في بيان انه تم اعتقال بعض الضباط
واخرين وما زالت عمليات البحث جاريه عن
اخرين من الضالعين في التمرد المزعوم في
باكستان مقتل 52 وا
اكثر من 100 بينهم عدد كبير من رجال
الشرطه جراء تفجير في ولايه بلوشستان جنوب
[موسيقى]
غربيه